thank you so much Steve a tremendous
pleasure to be here in fact I've already
been having so much fun talking to
people that I'm hoping I have enough
catecholamines left for today's talk
because we know or at least you will
know by the end of the talk but that
prefrontal needs that and prefrontal
needed for this talk so especially we
have so much the same goals but from a
complimentary perspective so trying to
understand how genetic insults affect
signaling pathways that then affect this
circuit function and lead to symptoms
and we're trying to bridge that by
really trying to see how these signaling
pathways interact to specifically affect
circuits in layer 3 of dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex which are so
tremendously affected in mental
disorders like schizophrenia and what
I'm going to be telling you today is we
are finding that these layer 3 circuits
are regulated at the molecular level in
a way that's fundamentally different
from classic circuits for example
fundamentally different from the primary
visual cortex and we've just started
studies as I'll show you some of the
data where we're actually recording and
looking at v1 as a direct comparison and
our overarching hypothesis is that these
unique regulatory events are part of
what makes dorsal lateral prefrontal
cortex and these circuits in particular
so vulnerable in cognitive disorders
such as schizophrenia and also I think
actually in age-related disorders like
Alzheimer's and already if you look at
the architecture of these cells you see
how special they are so if you compare
this is now rhesus monkey layer 3 dorsal
lateral prefrontal 2
3v1 more than twice as many spines twice
as many connections and if you look over
primate evolution from simple like gala
go all the way up to human what you find
is the number of spines is really the
same in v1 whether or not you're human
Galago whatever but in dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex you see this vast
expansion on the number of spines from
early primates
here's rhesus monkey and here's human so
this is where we're expanding it fits
with the vast increase in the number of
connections needed for higher cognition
and we see this in the basal dendritic
tree as well where it becomes quite
simple rhesus monkey more complex and
most complex of all in human so we're
looking at the circuits that are
evolving most in primate evolution and
that are also very different from
rodents so this is human dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex and this is mouse and
rat medial prefrontal since they don't
have a dorsal lateral region and one of
the things that I think is really
important for the entire field to
remember is in humans and rhesus monkeys
layer 3 is immense and these cognitive
circuits that we focus on that Pat
Coleman Rakesh discovered and that are
so affected in schizophrenia
particularly in deep layer 3 whereas you
see layer 3 is very tiny in rodent
medial prefrontal conversely layer 5
quite small in human and monkey and very
large in rodent so some of the
differences then that we might be seeing
and thinking of a species differences
might be laminar differences instead and
I'm hoping that it can be more research
on layer 3 in rodents
see if there's things that might be more
similar to human and might be a hopeful
way forward so when we talk about
differences to keep this in mind because
so much of the physiology in particular
in rodents has been done from layer five
layer three I say is particularly
relevant to these disorders particularly
deep layer three and this is where we
see the loss of neuro pill and the loss
of dendrites and spines in schizophrenia
this now iconic image from david lewis's
lab and david had has also now shown
that these deep layer 3 pyramidal cells
are profoundly hypo metabolic that they
are likely the primary deficit in
schizophrenia whereas the GABAergic
surrounding inter neurons a compensatory
weakening to make up for this loss of
connectivity and firing and we can see
this reflected at the imaging level
where hypofrontality of dorsal lateral
prefrontal correlates with symptoms of
thought disorder so this is not just an
epiphenomenon it is likely deeply
related to the distortion in cognitive
thinking I wanted to add that these
circuits are also really important for
age-related disorder these layer 3
pyramidal cells are what filled with
neurofibrillary tangles and dye and
Alzheimer's and this is what's
correlating with the onslaught of
cognitive impairment I don't have time
for that in today's talk oh I just
wanted to compare in comparison area 17
primary visual cortex almost no tangles
even in end-stage Alzheimer's disease so
I think this is a fascinating lesson
what makes these guys so resilient these
guys so vulnerable we're beginning to
see how phospho tau accumulates in these
cells and makes them vulnerable and if
you're interested we had a paper in PNAS
last year and
we're continuing to build on that and
just to say that I think the aging
rhesus monkey is a really excellent
model for asking these questions of why
some cells are vulnerable with age and
others not but I'm being disciplined and
not talking about that today and instead
so we can focus on schizophrenia and
questions more immediately related to
Stanley and so what is making these
layer three circuits so vulnerable I
think part of it is this differential
regulation and so let's first review
what classic calcium cyclic A&P
signaling does for example in
hippocampus in a dish in developing
visual cortex so the traditional role
here we have glutamate release and NMDA
and r2 a we have calcium coming in this
is our spine apparatus which is the
extension of let me just fill in here
NMDA an ampere receptors so AMPA
stimulation by glutamate allows NMDA to
open we have the calcium entry which can
in many spines cause more calcium
release from the spine apparatus which
is the extension of the smooth
endoplasmic reticulum into the spine and
if we get enough calcium activation of
cyclic AMP e protein kinase a signaling
so we have feed-forward signaling here
as PKA phosphorylates ip3 receptors
causes more calcium release and if we
have enough of this from a very strong
synaptic connection we phosphorylate
CREB and get transcription where we now
create a strong mature spine and in
these classic synapses nr2b NMDA are
often extra synaptic whereas the a
subunit once in the synapse itself
needing AMPA receptors to be able to sit
in a depolarize membrane and open so
that's classic LTP
plasticity and phosphodiester aces PD
fours chew up the cyclicamp e and stop
it and weekend plasticity oops and
evidence of this in hippocampus NV one
the other common place for cyclic GMP
signaling is presynaptic where cyclic
AMP EPK activation Prime's vesicles and
increases transmitter release often
glutamate release so these are the
traditional roles of calcium cyclic AMP
II signaling and what we're finding is
that these signaling pathways do the
exact opposite in dorsal lateral
prefrontal layer 3 instead of
strengthening they weaken connections
and do so by opening a variety of ion
channels KC and Q HCN that are
themselves and have increased opening by
cyclic AMP E or PKA signaling and so
that is a lot of the data I'll be
telling you about today and this idea
that we have these built-in mechanisms
to weaken a connection if it's not
regulated properly you have a genie out
of the bottle
who can weaken and destroy connectivity
so we are currently comparing dorsal
lateral prefrontal to v1 in the rhesus
monkey to directly compare how
modulation works and again v1 little
affected in Alzheimer's modestly in
schizophrenia where marked effects in
dorsal lateral prefrontal and our
approach is threefold
we do immuno electron microscopy to
actually see where proteins are and who
they're interacting with in these
circuits we do physiology where we're
recording from these neurons in monkeys
performing relative
cognitive tasks and we eye on a furry
switch means electrically sprinkled just
a tiny amount of drug on to the cells
were recording from to see how it
changes their physiological signature
and this is such a small amount of drug
that it doesn't alter behavior but it
gives us a good idea of how these subtle
perturbations alter on neurons response
and then the third thing we do is
behavioural studies where we give drugs
systemically in the monkey to look for
things that might be potential cognitive
enhancers we also do some studies where
infuse drug into rat prefrontal to look
at effect on working memory and
occasionally local injections into
monkey prefrontal as well so this
threefold approach to try and understand
how these circuits are modulated I'm
gonna start with v1 if you get the least
amount of data and these studies are
still ongoing and what we do is the
monkeys are fixating and looking for
this fixation spot to dim a little and
they press a button when they see
dimming but as they're doing it where
we're flashing these fields identifying
the receptive field of the neurons in v1
that we're recording from and these are
classic feed-forward sensory circuits
and when we've been looking now at what
does cyclic AMP E calcium do in these
circuits and when we look at the e/m
level we see evidence for this kind of
classic signaling with a mushroom spine
where PD for a is localized in these
spines so probably in the past when
plastic changes occurred that this was
indeed involved but mushroom spines are
actually just a minority small minority
of the spines in v1
and though they are a minority of where
we see cyclicamp e signaling proteins
the main place that we see them is in
these glutamate axon terminals and if we
look blown up here we see them
concentrated around the vesicles near
the release zone and so we think that
what's going on is the classic PKA
priming of vesicles to enhance release
and indeed when we do recordings from
monkeys and I honor furries cyclicamp II
agents the data are fitting with that so
here is a neuron under control
conditions in black responding to a
visual stimulus and now when we give
increasing doses of a promo cyclic AMP
II which mimics cyclic AMP II and
activates PKA we see a dose related
increase large increase here also
background firing but this is greater
than this so it's an enhancement of
sensory firing so this fits with this
working model and it's something that's
been seen throughout the nervous system
for years that cyclic AMP II enhancing
the firing and although I'm not
presenting the data here because it's
still being recorded as I speak I should
say that we see dramatic effects of AMPA
receptors so that if you block AMPA
receptors in these monkeys tremendous
loss of firing also loss of firing if
you block NMDA and I want to just tell
you that because you'll see it's very
different once we get to prefrontal so
in quick summary of our preliminary data
from v1 we're finding that cyclic AMP II
related signaling strengthens um the
visual sensory processing of these cells
and that these are needing ampa and nmda
actions so no surprises but we needed to
validate that this was indeed true in
the primate v1 and now what we're
finding in prefrontal is totally
different
and the role of prefrontal is totally
different what it is trying to do is
represent information for example visual
space in the absence of sensory
stimulation and this is the foundation
of abstract thought we've been testing
it as you'll see in working memory
paradigm but also essential for top-down
executive control so this is very much
the work of Patricia Goldman Rakesh and
if anyone is interested I did this
review on the 10th anniversary of her of
her death so it came out in 2013
trying to capture the highlights of many
things she did to truly transform this
entire field because what she gave us
was the Micra search circuitry the
neurobiology of visual spatial
representation so in her work and we
continue this the monkeys are doing a
visual spatial working memory task where
they're again fixating on a central spot
and as they do so a cue comes on in one
of eight locations for just a half a
second goes off and now the monkeys
having to remember that location over a
delay period of several seconds and then
the fixation point goes off and that's
the signal for the monkey is now able to
respond and move its eyes or in some
paradigms move its hand and if they get
the correct location they get drops of
their favorite juice reward and over a
typical daily session there are hundreds
of trials where the cue randomly changes
its position so the contents of working
memory are constantly having to be
updated and this absolutely requires
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex play I
keep them here I'm going to do this so I
don't keep hitting that
so what Pat found in these were studies
with Charlie Bruce and Shintaro funa
Hoshi is that there are what she called
delay cells in dorsal lateral prefrontal
that represent visual space so here is a
neuron for example that fires across the
delay period on every trial where the
cue had been here but not any of the
trials where the cue was in these other
locations so here's a fixation the cue
period delay response all these trials
this neuron fires if the cue had been
here and it's remembering that location
but none of these others so you can see
if you get to the end of the delay
period and this neuron is firing the
brain knows it was here look here
whereas if it's not firing it it knows
it wasn't there does that make sense to
everybody
so this is the neural representation of
visual space and that in itself was an
enormous advance Pat also found more
typical sensory and motor cells in
dorsal lateral prefrontal some cue cells
that fire only when the cue is on
response cells that fire just before the
motor response and are probably
conveying this information to the motor
system and very interesting these cells
we call post saccadic response cells
that fire during or just after the
response that appear to be the corollary
discharge the feedback from the motor
system saying this is what I have done
these in particular are really
intriguing they're altered by dopamine
d2 I'm not talking about them today but
I think they're really important for
schizophrenia as well where there's
evidence of weakened or altered
corollary discharge but not for today
but I did want to make the point that
these cue and response cells have a
totally different pharmacology than our
delay cells they're huge amp of response
you block AMPA they stop firing and
we're now seeing some evidence that
these are also enhanced by cyclic AMP II
much more like the v1 cells much more
what's like has been seen in rodent and
again is this because rodent studies are
done in layer five or because their
species differences we don't know but I
just wanted to put that on everybody's
radar screen that you can't just say
prefrontal layer is really going to
matter circuit is really gonna matter
and let me now talk about this unique
regulation and the circuitry for these
delay cells so Pat discovered these
micro circuits in deep layer 3 that are
comprised of pyramidal cells that excite
each other
recurrent excitation so they're all
interconnected in these long horizontal
connections and this is what mediates
this persistent firing and allows the
cells to fire even without sensory input
because they excite each other and I'll
show you that this is utterly dependent
on NMDA receptors and then the cells
also have this beautiful spatial
specificity if they were firing to every
direction there'd be no information some
of this is due to the inputs from
parietal Association cortex being
somewhat specified but it is enhanced
and refined by lateral inhibition from
GABAergic cells so for example if the
queues at 270 degrees
this group of 270 degree pyramidal cells
are firing they activate a basket cell
which is a GABAergic inter neuron to
shut off our 90-degree cell so it is not
firing under these conditions
so lateral inhibition refining the
spatial tuning and allowing us to have
precise information held in working
memory
now these are the very circuits
most vulnerable in schizophrenia Pat and
when Solomon were the first to show this
very reduced neuro pill specifically in
deep layer 3 and then David's lab going
on to show the loss of dendrites and
spines that's most accentuated in in
deep layer 3 and this is probably due to
a combination of errors in circuit
formation in utero and then accelerated
loss in adolescence which I wonder how
much of this is stress driven as well
given the links between stress exposure
and onset of the disease in in late
adolescence and then there is also this
weakening of the GABA that david has
shown compensatory weakening of the
inter neurons but he thinks now a
primary deficit in these pyramidal cells
so we would then have weaker persistent
firing and noisier signals so being able
not being able to hold well-defined
information in mind and thus
contributing to thought disorder and
I've wondered how much of this relates
to these waves of gray matter loss in
adolescence so I'm hoping that our work
might be able to give some insights onto
that by studying the needs of these
circuits and why they're so vulnerable
so what we're finding is that the
arousal modulators have essential
actions on whether these connections
these recurrent excitatory connections
are actually effective and that this is
what allows mental flexibility to
coordinate with our cognitive and
arousal States so why you're all even
though it's 3:00 in the afternoon
so alert and interested because the data
is is so fascinating and because you all
had coffee which then increased as it
you're calming and then what these guys
are doing what we're finding is they can
very rapidly and reversibly alter the
strength of these NMDA synapses either
by opening potassium channels to rapidly
weakened a connection or if we're
interested as you all are now and feel
safe inhibit the cyclic AMP e signalling
close these channels and strengthen
these connections and as I said this
idea of this built-in mechanism to
weaken a connection confers
vulnerability when not properly
regulated by genetic or environmental
insults so let me show you some of the
data first of all that NMDA receptors
are there in the synapse and one of the
first things that we see that's
different is nr2b which are extra
synaptic in your classic synapses are
completely in the synapse only in the
synapse in these layer 3 circuits so the
only place we see them is in the
postsynaptic density none extra synaptic
and when we block NMDA receptors we see
this complete loss of representation so
here's a neuron representing 90 degrees
now when we block including if we just
block NMDA receptors with nr2b subunits
can you see how that representation is
gone now so there's no longer any
information held in mind we get the same
thing if we block an hour to a or if we
block both of them so they're all
important but what's interesting is that
nr2b is as well because these guys close
slowly they allow a lot of calcium in
and that's probably part of the
vulnerability profile so yes and I just
told you that a as well so both
both are important and in contrast
AMPA not so important so here's a firing
for the neurons just so this is the
preferred direction and this is one of
the non preferred directions so I'll
mostly just show you two to save space
so here's a neuron in blue firing for
its preferred direction under control
conditions doesn't fire for non
preferred if we block NMDA with nr2b
you can see this dramatic loss of firing
but if we block alpha very subtle
effects here in green the only time it's
significantly different I'm sorry this
standard error is hard to see but it's
quite wide this is the only segment
where it's at all statistically
significant and even then it's not much
so we were really surprised by this
because hey Anthes are essential for
NMDA this is impossible
so what's relieving the magnesium block
that allows NMDA to open and the answer
turns out to be acetylcholine is playing
this key role and our published work is
showing acetylcholine is doing this
through nicotinic alpha 7 receptors and
they're located right in the glutamate
synapses where the nr2b are so here's a
glutamate axon and the iam is showing
the alpha 7 or right there they're also
nearby in this cholinergic synapse and
you can see these spines are really thin
they're long and thin and we think that
architecture is essential for allowing
these gaining actions so allow these ion
channels to have such a huge effect so
you can to polarize this tip and allow
NMDA to open let me show you some of
these
know that when we block alpha7
we get a beautiful loss of firing and
conversely when we stimulate we get a
beautiful increase so here's a neuron
firing under control conditions and then
with increasing doses of an alpha 7
agonist and this is important for NMDA
we can rescue firing after blocking
lightly NMDA receptors but this is the
experiment that I found most interesting
normally if you spritz some NMDA on
these cells you get increased firing
that's not surprising but if we first
block alpha 7
the NMDA is no longer able to excite the
cell so it suggests you have to have
these guys depolarizing the membrane for
the NMDA to have an effect and we're
seeing similar effects now with
acetylcholine stimulating muscarinic m1
we don't know if they're in the same
synapse but it seems like acetylcholine
is it playing this really key role in
these prefrontal circuits and what's
fascinating to me is acetylcholine is
only a released one we're awake or in
REM sleep so not in deep sleep when
we're unconscious so is this part of the
basis for conscious thought that having
a CT of choline allowing these networks
to connect is allowing us to be
conscious I think that's a really fun
thought it's also very relevant to
schizophrenia where there have been
long-term genetic links to Ana weaker
NMDA and alpha 7 and is this why so many
patients with schizophrenia smoke to
strengthen these weaker connections and
I have heard patients describe
themselves when they're smoking that
they feel like they are appearing to
themselves and is that because they are
bringing more of these circuits online
and based on this long history and this
understanding about smoking alpha7
agonists are now being developed as
potential cognitive enhancers for
schizophrenia ADHD age-related disorders
and artists data suggests that this
could be a really fruitful strategy but
you really have to watch out for dose so
here is a neuron under control
conditions weakly representing 270
degrees with a low dose of alpha 7 do
you see how that information is
beautifully accentuated and how helpful
that would be but if you go too high and
you can go too high really quickly now
we have nonspecific excitation and the
information contained is actually lost
because now the cells just firing to
everything so dosage will be critical in
developing these agents as cognitive
enhancers now I want to turn to the next
really important phase of this which is
calcium and cyclic AMP e-cig 9 now we've
gotten our NMDA receptors open we've got
calcium coming in and we're discovering
this whole extraordinary apparatus which
provides negative feedback allows
Network gating and allows us to
disconnect and weaken these connections
very rapidly so we see the most of these
synapses in layer 3 have a
well-developed
spine apparatus connected to the smooth
ER with these calcium cyclic AMP East
signaling evidence of this cartoon right
there and I'll also show you with these
nearby ion channels so let's show you
the iam to support the cartoon first of
all we have evidence that a cap 6
anchoring protein 6 anchors PKA to the
spine apparatus so here's the dendrite
here's the spine neck the spine head
and the glutamate axon terminal and in
pink here you can see the spine
apparatus extends into the spine and
elaborates in the head and all along it
we have a cap six these gold particles
which are anchoring pka to the spine
apparatus and it's there's also data
not from my lab from others showing that
M glue are one and five are both
localized here positioned to drive that
we also think norepinephrine alpha-1
receptors might be there but we've yet
to do those studies so these would be
through IP three generation driving this
so they're positioned there and we do
have some physiological data to support
the M Gore one in five but I don't have
time to show that to you now instead I
want to go on and show you how these ion
channels are localized there first of
all HCN channels which open with
hyper-polarization but they're open
state is also greatly enhanced by cyclic
AMP E and we find that these h CN
channels are tremendously concentrated
in these spines right next to the
synapse and in what Konstantinos calls
the thin bottleneck the points in the
spine neck where it gets especially thin
the channels can bring it in a way like
nothing's going to get through and when
we block these channels with a low dose
of ZD 7 to 8 8 we get enhanced firing
and specifically preferred the preferred
direction when we go to high doses we
get a collapse and firing probably
because now we're blocking the HC on
channels on the distal dendrite that
normally serve to depolarize the entire
called dendritic tree but this was what
was most interesting to us that we could
get this enhancement as if we're
allowing in more of this network we're
also seeing a whole lot of kc n q
channels 2 3 & 5 and k CN q channels are
opened by PKA signaling specifically kc
on q 2 or if they're combined with 3 and
because of the work being done at the
stanley i wanted to mention that there's
work showing that GSK 3 beta might
interact with PK in increasing this open
state which may be particularly relevant
to bipolar we have not done work yet to
see if that's there but i wanted to put
that out there to try and link it to
some of the work being done here so the
e/m is showing all 3 2 3 & 5 we can find
all of them on spines in layer 3 and we
get very dramatic effects when we block
them we get the enhance firing and when
we open them we get the reduced firing
as we would expect and then we can drive
this by activating PK a so here's firing
under controlled conditions and now if
we give the a promo we get a reduction
in firing which is exactly opposite of
what we saw in v1 and we can reverse
this by blocking h CN channels and i'll
show you in a moment we get even greater
effects when
block pd4 and allow cyclicamp ii levels
to build up so we have both of these
channels and now let me show you how
dopamine through d1 receptors can drive
this through increasing cyclic AMP II
dopamine d1 have complex effects so if
you'll stick with me I'll show you this
we have these preferred network inputs
we're here a 90 degree cell is getting a
90 degree input also non-preferred
network input so here's a hundred twenty
degrees and I'm going to show you that
d1 can help carve away this
non-preferred when we have the dose is
just right so the e/m is showing
location of d1 receptors some of it
right in the synapse and the
postsynaptic density here and so I've
I've put that there and the evidence
suggests that this is now from rodent
but it fits with some monkey data that
d1 right in the synapse through PKA is
probably phosphorylating and MDA
receptors and keeping them in this sent
out and if you give huge doses of d1
antagonists and
do indeed stop all firing the other
place we're seeing them is right next to
the HC n channels and I've drawn these
as the cartoon out here there
usually right next door and what we see
when we activate these is for sculpting
actions where we take this noisy firing
from the non-preferred and sculpt it
away and you can see that this creates a
much better refined representation so
here's the neuron firing under control
conditions where it's preferred versus
non preferred directions when you give
d1 you really refine this so now you
have sharper tuning and just firing for
the preferred but when we give higher
levels which likely occur during stress
exposure now we have this huge loss of
firing and we are reducing the third
network inputs as well we also see this
huge loss of firing when we give
norepinephrine alpha one agonist and
this is through protein kinase C in that
if we inhibit PK C we can restore from
her and this ends up being especially
important with chronic stress where in
rats now chronic stress leads to loss of
spines from layer 3 neurons and we have
this correlation with loss of working
memory but if we inhibit protein kinase
C every day before the stressor we can
rescue spines and rescue working memory
and we've wondered if in part this has
to do with peak AC phosphorylation of
marks which disrupts the actin
cytoskeleton so this these acute effects
of stress we think contribute to the
chronic stress profile as well well
thankfully there's a whole bunch of
endogenous mechanisms for regulating
this feed-forward signaling
and allowing the networks to connect and
I'm just going to show you a couple of
these because they end up being so
relevant to schizophrenia so PD for a
phosphodiesterase turns out to be the
phosphodiester ace that is here next to
the spine apparatus so in pink we see
the spine apparatus this is a cap six
anchoring PKA and the green arrows
indicating the PD for egg throughout
there and what's anchoring it in the
correct place is this one disrupted in
schizophrenia so here's our glutamate
axon terminal our synapse the spine
apparatus which continues there as well
this large gold particle is attached to
an antibody that recognizes this one
these three tiny gold particles are
attached to antibodies that recognize
p4a
and you can see this is less than a
nanometer so this one anchoring PD for H
of the correct location to keep all of
this under control and indeed if we
inhibit P before we see this total loss
of firing that we can rescue by blocking
this channel so physiological evidence
for this interaction as well
interestingly inflammation impairs the
ability of disc 1 2 anchor PD for a 5
specifically not the other
phosphodiesterase is just this one so
it's a way where we could this is this
paper if you're interested in it a way
that inflammation can lead to
dysregulation of this pathways and
weakening of this connection I wanted to
share with you some of our newest data
that's not yet published but it's
directly relevant to schizophrenia and
that's M glue our three
em glory is traditionally thought of is
localized only in glia and in the Perry
synaptic astrocytes and what we're
finding is it is indeed in glia but the
other major place it is in layer three
of dorsal lateral prefrontal is these
exact thin spines postsynaptically there
it is right next to the synapse right
next to the spine apparatus position to
inhibit cyclic AMP East signaling and
indeed when we stimulate these receptors
we're seeing enhance firing and we're
working with jeff con scoop at
Vanderbilt hoping they can create a
selective and glue our 3 Pam because all
we've been able to use so far are these
M core 2 3 compounds and MgO r2 are
localized in particular presynaptic lis
there are some Poston in glia but the
presynaptic actions eat away at and
diminish the efficacy of these agents
and we think this is why they might have
failed so far in treating schizophrenia
so in schizophrenia then we're seeing
this whole constellation of things that
normally strengthen these synapses being
decreased or weaker in schizophrenia the
one thing I didn't talk about is our GS
4 which is positioned to inhibit GQ
signaling right there so these things
that strengthen are all weaker and then
conversely the things that weak in the
synapse are increased in schizophrenia
I'm glue r1 and d1 early in the illness
and I've also wondered this is a
speculation now but again based on the
sorry how that keeps happening based on
the the G wass data whether the l-type
calcium channel 1.2
is often focused in spines it is
increased actions by protein kinase a
it's known that the variant in
schizophrenia
increases its activity and it would then
through stimulation of for example
ryanodine receptors drive this weakening
process so I think this would be a
wonderful target for us to look at next
to see is it indeed in this position and
having these weakening actions though it
also shows how we can have this whole
variety of genetic insults that would
leave lead to the same phenotype of
weakened connection in the circuit most
needed for higher cognition and now I
want to close on a potential therapeutic
that's already successfully translated
to humans and that I'm hoping might be
useful in schizophrenia as well and
that's the norwich energic alpha 2 a
receptor which is also here on these
spines position to inhibit cyclic GMP
signaling so the e/m shows it right
there next to the HC n channels
sometimes it's right next to the synapse
and sometimes it's in the spine neck and
if we block these receptors total loss
of firing that we can rescue by blocking
these channels so these data really made
me a believer and if we infuse large
amounts of you him being into dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex huge loss of
working memory increased impulsivity
impaired regulation of behavior this is
the work from bombing Lee's group in
China who's been a longtime :
conversely if we stimulate this receptor
with guanfacine which is currently the
most selective alpha-2 agonist available
we see a beautiful enhancement of firing
and when we give it systemically a
beautiful improvement in working memory
reduce distractibility and enhanced
impulse control and we have been able to
see with systemic Wafaa seeing
improvement and working memory in mice
wild-type mice but not in alpha 2 a
mutant mice it's a small effect I think
if we didn't know what we were looking
for we wouldn't have found it but it
gives me hope that there is this small
signal there in the mouse and when we
give the chronic stress where we get the
spine loss if the animals are treated
daily with guanfacine prior to the
stress we rescue the spines and we
rescue working memory so it protects
gray matter as well and some of this may
be due to gwampa scenes
anti-inflammatory roles activated
microglia Express alpha 2a receptors and
guanfacine deactivates these microglia
and has anti-inflammatory effects so
both of these actions might be very
helpful in protecting prefrontal cortex
so based on our work guanfacine is now
in widespread use for treating
prefrontal disorders in humans it was
approved by the FDA in 2009 for the
treatment of ADHD under the brand name
in tuna which is extended release
formulations for children because they
metabolize it so quickly it's used
off-label as a first-line treatment for
Tourette syndrome because strengthening
prefrontal allows subjects to inhibit
their tics
it's used off-label and autism spectrum
disorders to treat the disinhibition the
ADHD like symptoms and an area where
it's particularly useful because not my
else is is in treating emotional trauma
PTSD in kids which often evidences as
oppositional or aggressive symptoms
especially in boys who've been
traumatized and it's one of the few
things that helps these kids to control
themselves and calm themselves down it's
also being tested in a number of other
prefrontal door disorders that where
it's still mostly laboratory although
it's extending into the clinic as well
so Tom McAllister is finding it useful
and treating mild traumatic brain injury
which so often affects prefrontal if
it's extensive prefrontal deficits or
destruction obviously there's no
substrate left but it can be helpful and
milder the Yale stress group is finding
it really helpful with substance abuse
finding it helps people quit smoking and
helping people who are cocaine addicts
to resist in particular helping them
when they're stressed to have the
self-control to not pursue it an
anesthesiologist at Vanderbilt uses it
to treat emergence delirium from
anesthesia he describes it he thinks
what's happening is the prefrontal is
still disconnected so when he's trying
to talk to them to tell them it's okay
you know this big thing in your throat
don't worry we'll take it out soon and
they can't understand him and panic and
it can be life-threatening because they
try to take out the breathing tube so he
now has developed an IV form of
compazine so he can give it right away
and the group in London is finding it
useful for treating strokes and
infections that generally afflict the
Association cortex and part of my visit
here really hoping it could help
prodromal schizophrenia perhaps help to
slow or even prevent that wave of gray
matter loss from prefrontal at the onset
of illness so I'd so hope that we can
collaborate and
help with understanding and treating
schizophrenia and I'd like to close with
many thank yous in particular the
physiology was done under the
supervision of min Wang the e/m
Konstantinos pest palace and thanks to
all of you